j'ai trouvé ta question non mais tous
les sujets qu'on a vécu c'est tout ce
qu'on a vécu les témoins que nous avons
reçu tout ça mais pour ce qui concerne
l'image parce qu'il fallait en trouver
une alors je suis je me suis rappelé
la façon que tu as de parler avec nous
et de jouer avec nous parce que tu
n'aimes pas perdre si tu veux ah quand
j'ai triché avec toi je sais voilà c'est
l'image
de Fort-Boyard je me rappelle
donc
c'est pas désagréable
vous pouvez rester voilà pour les
caméras sinon on voit plus rien merci
merci ça m'a fait plaisir merci merci
beaucoup
merci Raymond c'est Bernard Montiel qui
faut regarder
merci merci
Fort Boyard quand j'avais pris quand
j'avais pas triché d'ailleurs c'était un
jeu de mémoire et je t'avais battu
regardez
c'est le jeu décisif
jouer avec un daltonien mais j'ai arrêté
le cinéma pour ça moi tu nous emmerdes
c'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
on peut voir alors allons-y rouge rouge
jaune jaune bleu
quelle mémoire estonnante et jaune
[Applaudissements]
on fait un fou rire depuis ce matin avec
les équipes avec cette darka
[Applaudissements]
les chéris bien entendu il y aura
d'autres triches l'année prochaine
Valérie Bénaïm ma chérie alors moi j'ai
deux adjectifs incontournables et
exaltante vous pouvez faire des phrases
c'est un apéritif je pense que TPMP est
devenu une émission incontournable parce
que elle a su évoluer avec son temps et
elle a su muer et muté
et parce que effectivement dès qu'il y
avait une actualité dès qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui se passait dans la
société française le soir même ont
retrouvé les acteurs de cette actualité
dans
c'est mon fils ça va c'est bon
j'ai
failli laisse tomber
c'est mon fils c'est bon il a raison il
a réussi il a fait tomber c'est que ça
devait être par terre oui alors de fait
ça en découle à partir du moment où
c'est là où ça se passe et ben pour nous
c'est exaltant parce qu'il faut être il
faut être bon il faut être là il faut
être présent et donc voilà alors moi
c'est par rapport au fou rire de tous
les camarades ben c'est lie à quoi c'est
lié au fait que on fait des imitations
que vous faites des imitations ça part
de là c'est parce que s'il y a pas
d'imitation il y a pas de début de fou
rire et donc moi c'est toute la famille
petite Manning Michel
merci regardez
ce qu'on appelle le docteur
personne donc il va le garder donc
surveillance oculaire demain il sera
donc avec les copains du speed
[Rires]
il est 8h30
le bar s'appelle le Chupa Chups
ce serait introduit avec un camion benne
dans le rectum de la personne
[Applaudissements]
elle est incroyable et même le DJ speep
il était très fort je suis désolé
comme moi je voulais dire qu'on dit
souvent qu'on reconnaît le bonheur au
bruit qu'il fait quand il s'en va et le
fait de mettre l'éloigné à certains
temps du plateau m'a fait encore plus
prendre conscience du kif que c'était
des retours de la table et du coup ben
je suis très content d'être là et je
suis content
tu as fait une année incroyable une
demi-année mais on l'a pas vu on a cru
que tu avais fait ça
touche parler que des mecs qui ont fait
toute l'année
c'est comme image j'ai choisi comme TPP
c'est une famille et on lâche quoi
c'est une famille et voilà et comme on
l'age on lave bien son âge en famille
moi je fais les moments j'ai préféré
c'est quand il y avait des dosses qui
sortaient entre chroniqueurs et qu'on se
balançait un peu des histoires dans la
figure et ça ça me fait vraiment toi
même quand j'étais fou de la merde en
fait non parce que j'étais inconflé donc
je voudrais voir
aussi
pas trop non plus quand même le pousse
pas trop parce que j'ai des photos de
m'envoyer toi des photos de toi nu
chez elle
une table une table basse et des
fauteuils en cuir
[Applaudissements]
il y a une émission à faire
là
[Rires]
vous savez vous le savez très bien
c'est dommage
ça serait dommage que ça se termine
comme ça
[Musique]
la vérité
voilà je pense bien fermer votre gueule
[Rires]
comme tous les jours on oublie tout ça
nouveau rentrons ça va mon chéri ça va
super bien alors t'es heureux je suis
très heureux et moi le mot qui me vient
c'est liberté c'est la liberté de
s'exprimer la liberté de dire de penser
de débattre parce que je trouve que
autour de cette table à chaque fois j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'avis différents
parfois je me suis senti convaincant
parfois je me suis senti convaincu on
m'a fait changer d'avis on m'a renforcé
dans mes idées et tout ça je trouve que
c'est en fait le meilleur façon de faire
évoluer la société donc voilà pour tout
ça merci à tous
j'ai passé un mois super avec vous
c'est extraordinaire ce qu'il a dit mais
moi j'ai fait une vraie d'arcade parce
que en fait Gilles t'aurais rigolé parce
que il me regarde genre on est un peu
les deux maîtres des muscles bon très
bien parfait
très bien passé
pas aussi émouvant mais c'est
particulièrement drôle en fait c'est la
séquence qui m'a fait personnellement le
plus rire et en fait il n'a suffit que
d'un mot pour me faire rire je pense que
le mieux c'est de regarder les images je
vous laisse la surprise vous allez avec
Jordan Deluxe
[Rires]
tail
personnalité que j'ai reçu dans mon
émission qui m'a dit Guillaume on avait
fait une semaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça représente parfaitement Guillaume en
fait il était un félin il patiente
silencieusement
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il pourrait
c'est ce qu'on attend j'entends un smack
[Applaudissements]
déjà ça me rappelle des souvenirs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma maman s'appelle Louisette oui c'est
joli c'est mignon par contre non non non
non non non
[Applaudissements]
non
Cyril on arrête parce que moi je n'en
peux plus
Jean-Marc la famille
elle s'appelle comment votre maman non
mais elle s'appelle Esther mais c'est
plus quand même
exactement
je sens le truc arriver là ça me fait
peur je vais partir Cyril
c'est très jolie oui ça va oui alors
rien mais moi je le sais même pas
pourquoi je suis là
on m'a dit viens il y a 30 minutes je
suis venu vous savez que je suis très
fidèle
parce que c'est bon mais non pas ici
tu vas venir et tu vas venir ici vous
voulez ouais d'accord ok avec plaisir
merci à tous en tout cas de l'avoir
passé des extraits cette année dans ce
Jordan d'avoir parlé merci beaucoup à
Kelly parce que tu es toujours très
gentil avec moi c'est pas le cas de tous
les chroniqueurs mais franchement
j'ai le Verdun
je crois franchement
[Applaudissements]
il faut que vous alliez boire un verre à
la buvette avec vos amis ça vous fera du
bien
même en coulisses le matin m'emmerde pas
c'est la dernière
ça fait plaisir de faire du mal à une
personne
gentil je t'aime beaucoup
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour toi ça met en marche mieux
[Rires]
sinon personne d'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
embrasse Sophie comme ça l'histoire
Daniel Moreau est d'accord et moi je
suis là d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en vacances avec moi s'il te plaît
alors c'est quoi toi qu'est-ce que tu as
passé une belle année j'ai passé une
super année
malgré une émission qui devient de plus
en plus sérieuse vers la fin parce qu'on
est à la pointe de l'actualité je trouve
qu'on se marre toujours autant au début
et c'est ça qui me plaît parce que moi
si je suis encore là aujourd'hui c'est
parce que je rigole tous les jours et
bah c'est une amoureuse
je suis là à la rentrée je suis très
heureuse
mais j'ai validé ça
sont confirmés pour la rentrée forcément
oui j'allais pas remuer le couteau dans
la pluie
[Rires]
oui alors et vous êtes contentes dans
votre nouveau petit camarade parce que
vous savez que Kelly Kelly c'est un peu
ma chouchoute et à côté il y a aussi un
nouveau chouchou à moi
alors ça marche très bien j'adore Hugo
très sympathique très bienveillante
j'essaye et tu sais que c'est vraiment
devenu un proche à moi
tellement proche tout à l'heure il m'a
montré son slip
alors on était dans la loge et on sait
tous montré la photo de notre meuf ou de
notre mec et on a pu voir donc voilà
tout ça et on a vu le bec de Sophie
Coste et très beau très sympa non
vraiment très sympa et sans filtre comme
ça je l'ai vu j'ai bravo oui bah c'est
tout je suis très heureuse d'être ici ah
un petit truc escale à rentrer non
malheureusement si je peux sauter là
depuis 6 ans il faut plus s'imposer plus
par l'effort alors crier
et vous nous voyez pas donc c'est juste
aux yeux donc je vous vois très bien
je mets ceux de fond je mets franchement
je mets des physiques
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu arrives là tu es au Paradis tu
arrives là ton affaire
[Applaudissements]
dernière émission pourquoi vous êtes pas
gentil bienveillant mais parce que ce
serait pas moi physique particuliers
mais quand même vous êtes très beau et
franchement vous êtes très beau et pour
des pour cette des personnes décédées je
trouve que vous tenez voilà
justement un jour je vous ai trouvé très
bienveillant et ça m'a super étonné je
me suis dit mais attendez pourquoi il
nous protège tant et c'était le bah
attendez même moi de le dire j'ai peur
c'est le chocolat regardez le mal
-être sur le plateau vous le savez
Wonder man allez pendant 2 ans
on voit que depuis quelques mois voir
quelques années vous avez entamé un
régime strict pour être au top
physiquement c'est pas vraiment un
régime c'est vrai que je m'entraîne
beaucoup voilà mais voilà j'ai pas de
régime particulier d'accord est-ce que
vous vous interdisez des aliments
j'en prends jamais et le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
juste pour ça applaudissement pour eux
merci qu'est-ce que j'aime ça
et justement on était étonné de nous les
filles d'être derrière et en fait vous
avez mis les hommes devant
la vérité non je dis au téléspectateurs
j'ai revu les images je pense que c'est
l'année où j'étais le plus beau gosse
le plus modeste
Valentin attention moi je suis iPhone
aussi qu'on adore
tout ça c'est la famille ça on va leur
on va leur on va leur faire un petit
bisou Gilles Verdez comment comment tu
as appréhendé ton année comment tu as
aimé ouais j'ai un mot moi c'est plaisir
plaisir de travailler avec vous avec un
chroniqueur et avec les équipes
franchement les équipes ont été
extraordinaires le matin dès qu'on sait
qu'on vient à la table parce qu'on est
prévenu en fin de matinée on bosse avec
eux ils sont en début d'après en début
d'après-midi on bosse avec les équipes
et tout le monde est tout le monde est
génial dans votre environnement c'est
extraordinaire moi ce qui m'a le plus
plus évidemment c'est les débats et
parmi ces débats j'en ai retenu un
qui a pas été tout à fait au bout de la
discussion mais qui a été très mouve
mentée la question du débat c'était
faut-il interdire la corrida et donc au
bout d'un moment et bien le débat c'est
fait avec Solveig la militante est
arrivé et puis en quelque sorte
illuminer le plateau donc c'est ce que
j'ai choisi
ici c'était si peu aimé il y aurait pas
des millions d'amis qui viendraient
toute la doc qui viendrait chaque année
au feria alors c'est Solveig je vous
présente mon épouse
[Rires]
c'est très dangereux
protagonistes moi je suis contre la
corrida on a un torero ici on a un mec
qui flotte
les mecs on va pas s'embrouiller avec
Solveig
mais on le fera malgré vous on le fera
malgré vous n'avez pas la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
je comprends pas tais-toi mais tais-toi
merci Daniel Moreau alors pour moi ça a
été une cure de jouvence quand je suis
arrivé ici j'avais un pied dans la tombe
et grâce à vous j'ai fait un grand pas
en avant donc vraiment énormément
j'ai rajeuni à votre contact et je vous
en remercie et un seul mot pour résumer
c'est émotion parce que on arrive on a
pleuré on a [__] ou presque
ou presque ou presque c'est ce presque
évidemment pourquoi c'est c'est elle qui
pose problème en fait
non mais c'est pour introduire l'image
c'est qu'en fait évidemment il y a eu un
événement people cette année la France
retenait son souffle pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé ce fameux 8 mars après le
match Bayern de Munich et comme
d'habitude Myriam peu la même Palomba
savait tout elle a tout raconté
tous les chroniqueurs ont décidé de se
rendre dans le domaine de Cyril Hanouna
série Les détendu et vraiment à la
victoire du PSG les chroniqueurs aussi
le match des marres et moi selon mes
informations et je vais utiliser le
conditionnel parce que c'est des
chroniqueurs anonymes qui m'ont apporté
cette information visiblement Daniel
Moreau aurait surré à l'oreille de Cyril
ce soir ton ballon va finir dans ma
culotte précisément ce qui se passe
c'est que
Cyril là il est un peu effrayé on va pas
se mentir et puis et puis à la fin du
match bah là c'est le drame Daniel
Moreau aurait demandé des relations
sexuelles non conventionnelles
[Rires]
hier soir et il a marqué beaucoup plus
de but que le PSG
parce que
[Applaudissements]
franchement elle était avec nous cette
année aussi elle fait partie de la
famille d'amour et chérie tu m'en veux
que je t'ai mis
des fois ça m'énerve mais parce que moi
en fait j'aimerais bien t'imiter est-ce
que toi aussi tu as plein de types de
langue tu es là ouais ma chérie je vous
adore c'est trop darka
faut voir le faire
visiblement elle aimerait limiter
j'adore parce que Myriam Palomba elle
peut parler d'un truc vraiment ripoux
mais elle est toujours à fond Myriam
c'est ça que j'aime c'est professionnel
visiblement il aurait volé un
stylo-plume non mais c'est incroyable
c'est pas drôle mais quand même on
rigole bien franchement Myriam je
voulais qu'elle soit absorbe parce
qu'elle fait partie de la famille elle
sera avec nous l'année prochaine bien
entendu et on l'aime fort merci mamie
merci merci
Sophie Coste qui aime toutes les Kim les
belles choses
cette année c'est bon à chaque fois que
je viens ici c'est la récréation c'est à
dire que voilà il y a des espèces de fou
rire comme ça personne ne comprend rien
il y a des trucs en off qui se font et
en gros voilà il y a une espèce de
connivence quand même entre les
chroniqueurs de bienveillance et il y a
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est à
dire que dès qu'on balance un petit dos
en loge ou en off etc c'est WhatsApp
quoi faut faire très très attention à ce
qu'on dit très très attention à ce qu'on
montre et surtout faut pas être
susceptible heureusement je le suis pas
donc tout se passe bien est-ce que j'ai
retenu
[Rires]
j'espère pas parce que là les cheveux à
se faire
[Rires]
et ce que je retiendrai cette année
c'est alors
c'est quoi le problème c'est que vous me
chauffer un peu en dans dans entre les
entre les plateaux en off donc vous le
faites un peu avec tout le monde et moi
j'ai tendance à être assez spontané
s'appelle
en fait je suis naturel et voilà et ça
m'a fait marrer en fait la force
peut-être susceptible heureusement
vous imaginez la souffrance après avoir
vu ce que j'ai vu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai retrouvé votre mec ce weekend sur
ma vie
même force
tu vas moi je suis assez discrète quand
même sur ma vie c'était plus du tout
l'amour
ça fait cinq jours que j'ai Bacqué
un peu c'est un peu ça l'idée moi je
suis assez discrète quand même sur ma
vie
on est en direct c'est la dernière du 6
à 7 avec de TPMP bien sûr dans un
instant Raymond mon chéri tu es heureux
toi moi je suis très heureux et je suis
très fier de faire partie de cette
émission et tous les matins quand je
suis en livraison les jambes parlent
dans la rue je vois comment ils sont
contents de voir cette émission c'est le
rendez-vous ils disent tous aller à ce
soir à soi et qu'on mesure la chance
qu'on a de pouvoir débattre sur des des
faits d'actualité il y a tellement de
gens derrière leur télé qui qui
voudraient aussi donner leurs avis et
tout ce qu'on a fait sur cette émission
sur l'actualité en fait on a parlé de
sujets en premier c'est pas ce que tu as
raconté c'est vrai on a été sur des
sujets où personne voulait y aller et le
lendemain tu te dis [__] comme par
hasard ils en parlent seulement
maintenant mais personne n'en a parlé
pendant deux semaines pendant 3 semaines
pendant même des fois un mois personne
n'en a parlé donc je suis très fier de
de ça ça a été une saison très très dure
je pense sur l'actualité comme comme
disait Kelly vers la fin c'est très très
dur vers la fin on en prend plein la
gueule avec des sujets qui on ressort on
est on est on est vidé mais tu tiens ça
à la barque et tout c'est très bien tenu
les gens sont contents moi franchement
je suis fier je suis vraiment fière
je te fais des vidéos des fois le matin
je t'envoie des vidéos alors peut-être
ça te casse les couilles
et les gens continuent à venir en parler
quand vous voyez en livraison continuer
à venir en parler ça fait ça me fait
énormément plaisir et je suis vraiment
c'est on a une chance incroyable d'être
là et en plus on est payé c'est vraiment
incroyable ça tu vois on a choisi quoi
comme image moi j'ai choisi le jour où
tu m'as demandé de faire le comédien
tu vas devoir dire je ne pourrai pas
être au tribunal à 14h30 donc là tu vas
le dire énervé et ben écoutez-moi bien
monsieur Abou faudra que vous soyez au
tribunal demain à 14h30 je ne pourrais
pas être là demain à 14h30 mais
oui
j'ai compris
je vous attends que vous le vouliez ou
non à 14h30 demain au tribunal je ne
pourrai pas être là demain à 14h30 au
tribunal
mais la même étonné alors attends je te
redis la phrase monsieur Abou on vous
attend demain à 14h30 au tribunal
demain à 14h
[Applaudissements]
là tu l'as fait triste tu es vraiment
très triste je suis à bout
on vous attend demain au tribunal à
14h30
je pourrais pas être demain au tribunal
à 14
à demain pourquoi pas demain après
demain
je peux pas et tu peux me la faire
menaçante ah oui mais ça c'est ma vie
[Rires]
monsieur Abou
nous vous attendons demain à 14h30 à
14h30
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il a raison en fait Raymond on en
prend plein la gueule en fait moi mon
mot c'est feu d'artifice parce qu'en
fait quand on fait cette émission c'est
un peu un feu d'artifice c'est-à-dire
qu'on regarde un peu comme ça on est à
la fois spectateur et acteurs parfois on
a la boule grande ouverte parfois on est
merveilleux parfois il y a ça s'accélère
parfois ça ralentit et il y a toujours à
la fin un bouquet final donc vraiment
pour moi c'est ça qui caractérise cette
émission et je présente mes excuses à
Guillaume parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup ri c'était cette année et qu'il
fallait pas et je me souviens
particulièrement d'un fou rire avec toi
c'était avec Mr France et je dois dire
que ça a été bah on l'a beaucoup
reproché mais cela dit ça fait aussi
beaucoup de bien rire quand il faut pas
rire voilà et donc voilà c'est mon
moment
tu as l'air content
[Rires]
est-ce que tu te considères comme un
comme un beau gosse forcément
depuis samedi soir tu as fait quoi là
pour savoir j'ai participé à différents
plateaux TV donc ce matin je suis passé
à France Bleu j'ai fait aussi des radios
tu sors j'arrive
on la met la connerie joie il était très
gentil
quand même très très bon choix très bon
choix là mon Guigui moi pareil ce que je
retiens c'est fou rire je trouve que
comme d'un côté l'émission elle a jamais
été autant au cœur de l'actu avec des
sujets très sérieux on a même créé
l'actu cette année ça qui était fou et
d'un autre côté je trouve qu'on sait
jamais autant marrer on n'a jamais
autant ri avec vous et que Géraldine
avec Kelly on se tape vraiment débarque
à toutes les émissions et moi je me
souviens il y avait un mec de la brigade
de défense des rats et une fois et
c'était un comédien et nous on sait pas
quand c'est des comédiens donc moi je me
tapais vraiment une barre en premier
degré sur le mec j'étais mort de rire et
regarde
consiste votre métier alors la b2r c'est
la brigade des répressions de rat c'est
à dire mais sérieusement
embêtés par des rails nous appellent et
nous on arrive et on les a 10h quoi en
fait mais exactement
[Rires]
et vous savez qu'il souffre mais
évidemment que je sais qui souffre mais
c'est parce qu'il souffre qui font du
mal 67 % d'entre eux
ils appelaient que le Bushido est-ce que
vous savez
mais c'est un art martial qui est très
connu
chez les rats
non mais c'est pas sérieux
en Asie il faut des combats et je mets
pas dit le nom de cette race ça
s'appelle des punjas
en Asie en Asie il faut les laisser
définir est-ce que vous avez un spécimen
[Applaudissements]
quelle rigole et moi moi le problème
c'est que je sais je sais que c'est des
comédiens à chaque fois à chaque fois
les équipes me disent Cyril [__]
essayez de pas rigoler à chaque fois
c'est possible c'est insupportable je
n'y arriverai jamais je n'y arriverai
jamais